man i watched this documentary this like
miniature documentary on youtube about
john mcafee last night have you looked
at this you looked at all of this [ __ ]
it's crazy
i used to pay attention to him he was
the man so the john mcafee stuff's
wild yeah and he legitimately said
you know and this isn't getting any
coverage because of whatever
you know maybe my little you know
circles of getting coverage but
to the real world the guy well yeah you
can i don't know if you're gonna like
intro or whatever you go away man you
tell you tell the story i'll jump in
yeah so mcafee he
you know he invented mcafee antivirus
became a big guy then he became like i'm
gonna be the exposing government secrets
guy
he was paying money on the dark web to
get all this stuff went to jail in
mexico
and there's lots more to that but he was
like heavy on the podcast scene like he
was out there
saying uh you know conspiracy stuff for
however you want to put it
and then he made all these videos in
jail being like
i'm would never kill myself like he has
a tattoo
he goes this is a tattoo that says i
would never kill myself
i love my wife i love my life and i'm
still
in perfect mental state but i have a
feeling they're trying to
and he just kept making these videos
like they're trying to kill him i will
not kill myself
and then the next day they're like
suicide
mcafee found dead in barcelona or
something yeah
[ __ ] man did you see so i watched this
jake tran
who's the youtuber he makes sick sort of
short documentaries if anyone wants to
find out more about this
mcafee situation i'll put the i'll find
the link and put it in the show notes
um he made the antivirus software
in a day and a half
took him a day and a half to code it and
within a month
four million companies were using it and
then within two years
half of the fortune 500 companies had it
on there
on their computers and it took him a day
and a half and then he got
some some guy that he lived next door to
supposedly poisoned his dogs and then
the next day that guy was found dead
and john mcafee was like don't know what
you're talking about
don't know what you're talking about
nothing to do with me
i didn't know that part of the story
wildman it was in some
some crit not venezuela but some equally
mental country
and uh yeah and then he had shwakt
didn't he
like dollar sign whacked on his
uh tattooed on his arm and that was also
his crypto that you could buy
but it was i'll never be killed and then
the final thing was he said um
he tweeted out that 16
terabytes of government secret data is
going to be released and i can't stop it
if anything ever happens to me but that
hasn't come out yet that sucks
yeah that's a bummer it did seem like
that yeah he
he was really hard on if i die
everyone's going down with me
and then he died and no one was still
waiting for the package
i know what is it because he's got a
lawyer that's tweeted something else as
well
saying um i'll i've i can't stop it once
the wheels are in motion there's no way
for me to stop it sounded like he's
setting off a
nuclear reaction or something but yeah i
mean yeah
that's what that's what everyone's
waiting for if he's got to be if he's
got to go and he was like 75 i mean he'd
had like
he'd lived a pretty crazy life given the
fact he was 75 but
and he was like this you know kind of
ladies man type
you know he was trying to be like a hugh
hefnery sort of situation for a while
like he was really letting
letting the money fly and uh trying to
live this dan blizzari any sort of
lifestyle
he was really into scat which according
to some of his ex-girlfriends
that she's an interesting insight
dude i always see like the damn blizzard
even went back if he was doing where
it's like i get the idea of at the end
of the night you know whatever
you're like i'm gonna have sex or do hot
chicks the damn blizzarian he goes on
these trips with like seven girls
it's like have you ever like hung out
with your like like a chick you're
dating and like two or three of her
friends
it's like what that's your life you just
hang out with these like seven
squawking freaking insta0s like that
that's your
imagine you go on a trip to a island
with just you and seven
annoying girls like this guy must be
like the biggest loser
like who the only person i could think
that would want to do that is like a gay
dude
like one of your gay friends be like oh
i'm hanging out with the seven chicks
like it's the thing that the
ambassadorian does he's like cool right
and i'm like i'd rather
shoot myself than be in a private jet
with like
seven models from instagram that don't
really know each other like what is this
well it's cool for the moment that that
photo was taken like if you were able to
maybe he's completely trolled everyone
and he just gets the girls in for that
and then they have to [ __ ] off and stay
in a different apartment
and he's just he just sits up late at
night like playing card and
reading philosophy or something yeah it
is the business model like i guess there
is a part of it where it's like
i get that where you're like no but i
have to do this because this is my
business as i go
take these photos price to pay man it's
a heavy price to pay but also why who
thinks this is cool
i'm just like like how does any guy fool
like
i can't i don't know a single guy that
would they would see like
seven you're like my chick and seven hot
girls are going on a trip and they say
that you could have
sex if you come when you go can i just
show up that night like do i really
this is what's insane this is where the
internet
gets things so much quicker than even
anyone else
because i was seeing dan bilzerian is
the ultimate man child
i was seeing videos with those sorts of
titles
18. oh the internet turned
yeah yeah exactly but you start to see
that well before
even like the other internet you think
there's so many layers to the level of
investigation that people are prepared
to do you know you mean
yeah they were so ahead of the curve
with that they're out of the curve with
like we don't like that anymore too with
things yeah as soon as
like there is a very if you're on that
pulse of the internet
when people are talking about that stuff
and you go in six months you'll hate him
you know what i mean like you can kind
of already see the like elon musk was a
perfect example of that
like what did you mean it was you well i
saw the
the he you know he was like on this cool
[ __ ] poster dude and everyone was kind
of like elon musk is sick and
doing the rogue appearances and all that
stuff and i could see the bumbling
underneath the people being like
this guy's a loser like you know what i
mean and like not even
the way that the media hated him where
the media you know lies about him and
doesn't like guys like him
i could see that people was like
regardless of that stuff it's like this
guy isn't
annoying thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace